Taiwan President Xiang won has stood
firm against increasing Chinese
aggression but that stance faces a test
in Saturday's local elections the vote
is seen as a referendum on her
leadership and that of her ruling
Democratic Progressive Party ahead of
national polls in early 2024 and Beijing
will be watching closely from across the
Taiwan Straits a strong showing by
opposition parties like the China
friendly kmt could influence who enters
government in a little over a year
the clock is ticking down to the poles
in Taiwan and candidates are doing
everything they can to win voters over
campaigning has been particularly fierce
in the capital Taipei
I am here because I'm concerned about
the future
I hope everyone can see the value of
democracy
everyone should go home and vote we need
to cast our votes for the person can
make the right choices for people these
elections are primarily focused on
domestic issues however the China factor
is still present in the background
president XI England and her governing
party have refrained the vote as a
message to China and the world that
Taiwan won't give in to threats
facing the rise of authoritarianism we
must Safeguard democracy we must have a
staunch attitude and the will to resist
and defend ourselves the better we're
prepared the smaller the danger to our
economy will be the more united we are
the stronger and safer Taiwan will be
the opposition or kmt which
traditionally favors closer ties with
Beijing has discussed the DPP for trying
to refocus the election on China its
chairman told supporters his party's
daunchly backs taiwan's freedoms
we are the political party that loves
Taiwan the most our biggest goal is to
defend the country
we just want to protect Taiwan
our most important mission is to
safeguard our democracy and freedom
both Party leaders have picked the
candidates themselves notation of the
Chinese culture University says the
outcome will reflect the leader's
influence on their parties and you will
likely be a Bellwether for the next
presidential election
if the DPP fails to meet expectations
Sai might have to take responsibility
for the party's performance so we can
see she has been showing up at rally
after rally and doing her best to Canvas
she wants to gain more votes for the
candidates she has chosen
it's unlikely the election will impact
cross-trades relations but analysts such
as Majin Wei said that Beijing will be
watching the results closely looking for
Clues as to where Taiwan is headed
if the kmt makes a breakthrough I think
this will ease tensions between Taiwan
and China to some extent
the Chinese government can use a kmt
victory for internal publicity and show
that their policy toward Taiwan is
practical effective and reliable
the latest polls shows the race is still
too close to call first results are
expected before early someday